gene is with us in colorado springs hi
gene
welcome to the ramsay show hi
thank you so much for taking my call
without going into all the glory details
my husband and i have accounts
we just put the house in both our names
i have no debt
he already had a home equity loan on the
house
plus a car loan now he wants to borrow
more money to buy some firearms
and with the hosting in both our names
it's
joint tenants not survivorship i would
have to find
some papers to say i can
consent to him getting a lien on the
house
should i do it to buy guns
yes how old are you guys
i'm 68 and he's 76. and how long have
you been married
over 15 years okay i have a huge gun
collection i'm a gun guy i can't
possibly imagine borrowing on my house
to buy a freaking gun
i'm a gun guy i'm your husband okay i
would i would be on his side but i can't
possibly imagine what
what gun purchase there could be that
justifies
borrowing on your personal home to buy
it
what is he buying a tank no
their single shot high wall
wall whatever and
he went to us he went to a gun shop and
they had these great deals and he knows
he could get
a lot of money off selling them
yeah he doesn't need to get in the
firearms business
at 76 years old by borrowing on his home
no i i i don't think this is a good plan
and if he called me i would tell him not
to do it and so i'm going to tell you
not to
allow your home to be done because when
this all goes out sideways and he can't
sell these guns
uh for whatever reason as an individual
or a collector or whatever he's getting
into here i can't tell what the flip
he's getting into but
uh it must be a very expensive
collectible gun of some kind of sound
sounds like he got a great deal he
thinks oh i can buy this now hold on
from a gun shop
he's going to steal it from a gun shop
yeah like they're going to give him a
deal so he can make a lot on it i got
questions yeah i'm thinking ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding warning
warning warning
because that's what retailers are known
for dave yeah they're known for giving
things away at cheap so you
can make more money on it later yeah
gun shops are known for not having no
idea the value of the guns in their
shops
we're being sarcastic your husband's
plan
sucks don't get into debt to do it